good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 4999 object
class safe special containment
procedures due to SCP 4999 s
unwillingness or inability to appear
before more than one person at a time in
addition to the subsequent and immediate
death of any who witness at first hand
SCP 4999 is effectively self containing
any reports of SCP 4999 manifestations
captured by security camera feeds
photographs or similar are to be
investigated and the media confiscated
for analysis all second hand witnesses
among the civilian populace are to be M
neste sized description SCP 4999 is a
humanoid entity of unknown composition
visually resembling a middle-aged male
its physical appearance varies with its
dark suit being the only constant
between manifestations due to the rarity
of recorded SCP 4999 manifestation
events and the highly specific
circumstances in which they occur little
data concerning its nature or intent is
available however its behavior is
consistent across all recorded sightings
SCP 4999 will manifest only in the
presence of one solitary human person at
a time all subjects recorded to date
have been internally poor health
critically injured or on their deathbeds
with a CP 4999 appearing nearby and
within sight of the individual not more
than 20 minutes before their expiration
SCP 4999 will only appear if the subject
is conscious and alone
it will not appear if the subject is
comatose asleep or unconscious nor will
it appear if they are being cared for by
or in the company of
otherwise being directly observed by
another person upon manifestation the
entity will cede itself directly
adjacent to the subjects bed
if such furniture is available if not it
will remain standing or sit on the floor
or ground in whatever configuration will
allow it direct physical access to the
subject without causing disturbance once
situated it will remove a pack of
cigarettes from its left inside jacket
pocket and offer one to this subject if
the subject accepts as CP 4999 will
place it between their lips remove one
for itself and light both if the subject
declines a CP 4999 will light and smoke
the cigarette instead the entity will
make physical contact with the subject
typically via holding their hand placing
its hand to top theirs or resting its
hand on their shoulder as CP 4999 will
then remain with the subject silent and
unmoving until they have passed away as
CP 4999 has not been seen to engage in
any other activity or behavior and D
manifests immediately upon the subjects
death the subject cigarette however will
remain providing the only physical
evidence of SCP 4999 s presence no
subject thus far has been seen to recoil
from or otherwise resist the entity nor
have any attempted to engage it in
conversation despite multiple instances
of subjects acknowledging the entity's
presence via eye contact adjusting
posture to reciprocate or facilitate the
entity's touch breaking into tears when
noticing its presence or verbally
thanking the entity when offered a
cigarette individuals affected by SCP
4999 share a number of common attributes
research into identified subjects has
indicated that a CP 4999 is more likely
to appear if an individual lives alone
his non-religious is impoverished or
homeless displays a history of mental
illness is a military veteran
no criminal record or has never been
convicted of a violent crime as no
currently surviving family is unmarried
or otherwise lacks a significant other
has little to no social standing in the
community does not exhibit any record of
significant professional or personal
accomplishments as few to know mutually
beneficial interpersonal relationships
or exhibits qualities and life history
that have rendered the individual
nondescript anonymous neglected or
otherwise unremarkable or insignificant
by the standards of their respective
society no testing involving a CP 4999
has been authorized or attempted due to
available data indicating that
observation of a subject precludes its
manifestation as well as ethical
concerns discovery
SCP 4999 was initially discovered as the
result of its emerging status as an
urban legend with footage of an entity
appearing on hospital security cameras
worldwide being disseminated via the
internet and various television programs
a minor disinformation program was put
into effect to maintain this public
image and as CP $49.99 was officially
registered on November 27th 1998 in the
years following SCP 4999 s
classification additional research and
cross-referencing with accounts of
similar phenomena have suggested that
while concrete evidence of SCP 4999
appearances has become more commonplace
due to the advent of photography and
video recording technology in the modern
era writings and artistic depictions of
a figure exhibiting similar properties
behavior and physical resemblance to SCP
4999 exists throughout world history
culture and mythology with some accounts
being thousands of years old in some
cases predating human civilization it is
not currently understood how pre-modern
cultures would have been capable of
detecting SCP 4999 s presence
investigation is ongoing
there isn't a lot of SCPs that restore
your faith in this universe but man this
is one of them but that about does it
for today thank you for listening if
indeed you still are and you're all
dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to curva gaming Zach Geller
James Saba Katherine June's Jax Merrick
Pablo ice 917 Burlington the cat Karim
Allah schmoovy
Justin de Pury kuma Riley Shawn Murphy
Traver W peg white crew Nicholas James
vu Jack Bryson Bailey my archive curator
neck tie verbal Alex Gill Dre rook the
Android Jacob Ganim pity quartz 5 6 3
and treat you if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos and some other cool stuff as
well visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volga thank you
you
[Music]